well on this Veterans Day we look back
at those military members who seek a
life in the civilian world after serving
some struggling to adapt like the case
of Andrew ho tonight he shares his
journey and what helped him get through
this process
I wanted to serve just because I wanted
to make my parents proud thirty-year-old
Andrew ho enlisted in the Air Force and
served for seven years when his contract
ended he says continuing his education
was his goal but adjusting to civilian
life was not easy it was a little rough
I didn't really know too many people
obviously all my high school friends
already graduated college so it's a
different experience that's where
executive director Ross Bryant comes in
spearheading unlv's Military and
Veterans Services Center he says its
focus is to help every generation of
veterans come back to the classroom if
you think of like the Vietnam generation
there was not a lot of services to help
in their transition and every generation
has a transition whether you did 25
years like me those Services include
admission VA education benefits
financial aid and employment
opportunities UNLV also recognized
nationally for being military friendly
as a top 10 school for its diverse
programs these vets are coming back
after some of them fighting a war and
being in a culture where you are on a
Super Bowl team and you have that
camaraderie where everyone takes care of
you when you have a challenge and you
help you take care of others today ho
serves as a mentor for incoming student
vets and has been nationally recognized
for his leadership as the country honors
those that served on Veterans Day ho
says it's the love from the community
which makes it all worth it just to give
back what means is giving back being
appreciated
will the military and Veterans Services
Center just celebrated their 10th
anniversary and their campus office is
full of unlimited resources the same
tools that host has is helping him
achieve his Doctrine degree